a warning her report contains images of
people who have died in the earthquake
these were once houses people's homes
the devastation in idlib and Northwest
Syria is immense and they know all about
Misery here
they've endured 12 years of war now
they're fighting to survive a natural
disaster and they're doing it in the
awful realization that once again
they're on their own
[Music]
so they dig through the night the white
helmets so used to pulling people out of
bombed buildings now trying to sift
through Rubble to find those who
survived the war only to die trapped and
terrified in the earthquake
they've just found the body of a
four-year-old boy still in his pajamas
his father can hardly contain his
Despair and disgust at how he was left
to die alone with no help from outside
who is helping us
in Turkey they're getting everything
they've made a special air bridge to
bring aid from all around the world
no one is coming to help us what did
this child do wrong to stay four days
underground before we found him
hello
and the agony is not over yet for him
the helmets are trying to find his wife
and his Elder son who's 10 both are
still missing the people here are saying
this is a real tragedy because it could
have been all so different if they'd
been given extra Specialists more
sophisticated equipment with which to
try and locate these people remember
some have already been taken out of here
alive but now the chances of finding
anyone else alive are extremely remote
they're exhausted but they go on
I've escaped the agony of loss either
through the wall or now the earthquake
they know the importance of finding at
least the bodies to grieve and pray over
here
have you found anything no is the
constant answer even finding the body of
a loved one is some small comfort in
this part of Syria where Comfort is a
scarcity
I also lost my son I feel the same
sorrow because I lost family too I know
this man is tortured inside to find his
wife and son is a matter of life or
death for me
two fathers with a bond of suffering
binding them together a common
understanding of the agony of losing a
precious child
the search goes on all night
the head of the militant Rebel group in
idlib turned up to offer support and
give a rare interview and he was
blisteringly critical of the world's
response
they're taking too much time and it's
costed lives for those trapped under the
rubble we've lost a lot of lives because
of the weak response of the
International Community they're the ones
responsible
yeah
he was once a member of the terror group
Al-Qaeda before forming his own islamist
militant group now focused on fighting
AQ as well as Isis and the Assad regime
in Damascus he has a 10 million dollar
bounty on his head but he tore into
Western leaders for ignoring the needs
of civilians in idlib
the people who died in the earthquake
were not terrorists who were innocent
civilians they were women and children
so to confuse humanitarian issues with
politics as a big problem
there are only bodies coming over the
Turkish Syria border in any quantity
right now little meaningful Aid has made
it across
these are people who have fled the war
in Syria to find sanctuary in
neighboring turkey
now being returned in body bags it is
the saddest of homecomings for their
relatives
so they're having to make Mass graves in
idlib to cope with the hundreds coming
home from across the border as well as
those who've perished here they simply
can't make them quickly enough
they were already struggling with the
impact of an unequal War now more
unbearable loss
a final kiss for a newborn baby a life
cut off before it had even really begun
this is a tragedy on top of a grinding
war and earthquake Calamity they're
talking here of deaths after the Quakes
caused by poor medical facilities of the
struggle without shelter of the need for
food and water of the urgency for just
about everything
so there is misery upon misery and the
News no one wanted
Celine found his wife and Son's bodies
and with that Discovery a whole new
depth to his suffering
he's now lost half of his family two
sons and their mothers
[Music]
there seems no end to grief life for
them is all about death
Saleem has to somehow console his one
surviving daughter eight-year-old mace
calm down my daughter he says okay my
love
this is God's will yeah
do you love me
I'll always be with you he says
foreign
they have each other but that is all
trauma in idlib never seems to stop it
just gets worse and worse
Alex Crawford Sky News in idlib Syria